tell us about polynomials and random
permutation an opportunity to very nice
workshop so I'm going to to speak about
the joint work work joint work with sir
shall bother Navin
okay so that's just to archive reference
look at them and details so basically
what we are interested in is to study
the joint behavior of random
permutations so I will denote this not
these permutations by s1 down to SK and
so so they they belong to the symmetric
group on an element which in turn I'm
saying as a permutation matrices so this
is n by n matrices ins well very soon
you will tell
complex principle to to investor the
permutation matrices but I will want to
want to allow me to to take some some
complex valued linear combinations so I
I've you everything as as living in in
this matrix algebra and what I assume is
the item all these matrices are random
dependents identically distributed and
they are distributed according to the
haar measure on the symmetric groups on
the uniform measure so here it just
means that the probability that this
that a given permutation is take some
value is 1 over N factorial since I will
be interested in in a large and behavior
I will put this here so I will always
assume this waitress's to be this so
what what I see as random matrices to be
able to be independent I could assume I
could assume that so if n is if n is
even so if n is 2 and prime I can assume
I may assume assume that part of the
matrices
our Rhonda major from the meetings so
actually
just to keep it simple I will take
random permutations but but we can we
can make some modifications on the model
and it will not affect the results which
I want to which want to present today so
what do I mean by by the joint behavior
typically what it means is that if I
take a polynomial in know committing
entries in in the three group on K
elements
so this is maybe it's not just standard
notation this is this is the free group
regroup on K elements this is generated
by the same G 1 G K where there is no
relations except no GI Joon vs.
and so let's let's take an example
progress let's say I would like to study
maybe just for the sake of simplicity we
will assume that it's a self-adjoint but
we're in the sense where the adjoint of
GI is its inverse so let's say for a
parade like to study here he is g1 g2
plus I plus G what universities we
inverse or something I could do so
coefficients or whatever so kind of you
know linear combination of words in in
the frequent and out of this I can
create I can create them a random matrix
which is just I replace GIS by my random
permutations so it's poison one one one
possible motivation for looking at this
Addison is you know we could think that
that this for example here becomes in in
this specific example which is which is
extremely specific it becomes the
incidence matrix of a graph you could
think of it as you could think of this
as a random graph on on on n vertices
and try to try to see what we can say
about this kind of random graphs so
specifically we are interested in the
spectrum behavior what I mean by by
joint behavior Hayes is behavior of the
spectrum of P n as n goes to infinity
so in my prime P ISM is given and I
would like to see what to see what
happens we make one you make one more
remark before I continue to effect which
extends I want to study the problem here
what I'm doing is I'm taking complex
valued coefficients linear combination
of words in the in the group of limits
in the free group with complex
coefficients I could allow myself
actually to take the linear combination
with with matrix coefficients so for
example I could have something ladies I
could have something like Q which will
be again I don't know it could be sons
if if l equals 2 for example I could
have a place I could have G 1 plus G 1
inverse and then G 2 plus G 2 inverse
and then I know G 1 G 3G 3 inverse and
XI 1 inverse whatever some things and
again I can think of this if I want so
at least if the coefficients are natural
numbers I can think of it as a as a
random graph but I'm going to to make
know no specific assumption on the
coefficients so what is the behavior in
this generation of the spectrum as n
goes to infinity well it is known it
follows from free probity and I would
like first to start explaining this here
free property free probity implies that
the the spectrum
4p n converges towards something
deterministic let me deterministic in
expectation as or as n goes to infinity
so to be more precise what I would have
to do here is I would have to so since I
took just for the purpose of simplifying
things actually I don't I don't need to
do that with my life slightly easier if
I take a self adjoint P here it means
that this guy will be sufficient as well
so I could describe the eigenvalues as
being I could arrange the real
eigenvalues in a decreasing order so I
could call them something this lambda 1
and bigger than lambda and and so here I
put an N but of course if it if there
had been if I had allowed myself here to
take matrix coefficients this could have
been Ln here as well okay and then I
look at the so-called eigen value
accounting measure so I can value
accounting measure which is 1 over so
which I will call mu of of PN which is 1
over N sum for I of the Dirac mass at
lambda I n so here again put an NL if
you what if if I put matrix coefficients
so P n is random so this is a random
sequence of n numbers Rondo non
decreasing sequence of n numbers so this
is a random probity measure and the
meaning of this random probity measure
is if I take an interval let's say it
means how many percent of eigenvalues do
I have in in this interval and what free
probity tells us is that there exists a
measure for a T measure mu we are valid
probity measure such that mu TN
converges so maybe I will keep my output
the expectation of MU P n so the average
converges converges to two new P so
again specifically it slightly more
specifically it means that if I check it
against test function so integral of f
of X D mu PN of X this converges towards
integral f of X D mu of X and here so
this is a random real or complex valued
variable so I I will take the
expectation let's say and this converges
and goes to infinity this fall so
appropriate a choice of test functions
so typically we could we could take
bound it or compactly supported the
continuous functions it turns out that
it is enough by some elementary
approximation properties to to take
polynomial
even real-valued prisoners would be be
enough so let me explain a little bit
how how how this works what you place
enough is to prove it
it's for monomers
it for modern yards and this case what
what one has is that what one just has
to observe is that the expectation of
integral integral of X to the P D mu PN
X this is the expectation of the
normalized trace of my random point
amela the power P which itself is it yes
let me thank you
so P reason elements of this algebra so
is P to the power P so again by
linearity it's enough to prove it
so it's enough 1 which works them out
one after the other
okay thanks
so if I yeah I'm sure
oh maybe I'm not holding it properly so
if I if I expand so it's enough
please award
not a combination of work but just just
the word and here actually we have an
old quite old wizard from I see for
Anika of the off the phone and Anika
which says that so even so I will we
will press T PI by W for forward if they
take him just just the words in the in
the group and I replace like before each
generator by the random permutation
let's take a non forget words and trace
of the random permutation which is
obtained by replacing instant generator
by the rotation has expectation which
goes to 0 as n goes to infinity what it
says basically is that the test if you
want to expected a percentage of six
pots quite a nice reason some Holly not
very difficult to prove it's as soon as
they take you know
a word which is non-trivial if I look at
the permutation which I which I obtained
from there it will have only few fixed
points the trace is the number of fix of
exposure and by the way this is in free
probability we have a fancy word for
this we say this is a statically free so
s 1 and s KN are asymptotically
you know you know what what free gravity
is that's all what you need to talk
about about free probity and basically
it's enough - that's enough - to prove
this that it's almost disappointing
that's that we just need this - to
conclude that we have the existence of
such a priority measure but that but
that's just how it is
and from this not two directions that we
can that we can take the first one is
what does what does this measure look
look like so I'm not going to go into
developments
so what does mu P look like and another
one which is the one about which I want
to to speak today is do we have outliers
so let me explain
yeah elaborate a little bit dope on the
first point first
somehow this result has been known in
the in the 90s but there is a little bit
of frustration due to this result
because let's say if you give me a
measure move okay if you give me a
polynomial can I create can they kind of
compute the measure mu P not really
actually it's quite difficult to
computer to compute the measure so
nowadays there is so actually if instead
of taking random permutation we we had
taken some more complicated matrix
models then there was a tool which is
which is called the Volcker risk with
our transform to to makes some
composition in some cases but even that
was not not systematic enough enough in
a sense and nowadays there is the very
general algorithms for computing mu P
which have been developed by one by many
people including Belinsky
many others so in principle nowadays if
you if you give me or if you these guys
your favorite polynomial they can put it
in a computer and tell you tell you what
what you PM will look like and there are
many other things which are which are
known many theoretical properties which
are known about about mu P for example
it is known that except if Pisa is a
trivial mu P will has no atom for
example it's known that in the case l
equals 1 and the spectrum is a is
connected orders lots of lots of
properties which are which are quite
nice whose proof in general requires
either some some smart arguments in this
queue fields or always we start at the
brain and all this but anyway quite a
few it is known about this and what I
want to discuss is is the other part
which is a do we have outliers so here
what what do I mean what do I mean the
thing that we know for sure is that mu P
has compact support bounded we're adding
bounded bounded things but the the
dumped bound that that we could set on
the on the support like you know there
it's it's at most the sum of absolute
values of of all coefficients appearing
in the sum or whatever are very gross
bounds which which are not that not
which are not the right bounds and so
let me know let me draw a limiting
limiting distribution what what this
result tells us is that so this is let's
say this is my my new Atene distribution
but this will tells me that if I take if
I look
let's see a compact set which is which
has no intersection with the support of
the measure what this tells me that I
have little off and eigenvalues there
that's all what what asymptotic free
Ness tells me as soon as I don't have a
macroscopic amount of them of
eigenvalues I don't see them and then
the limit in support is zero but so any
eigenvalues which would be here would be
called we would call it an outlier and I
can value which is epsilon away from the
from the limiting support away from the
limiting support
and well we can have our players it's
possible to have players so players can
happen of course and the most current
nickel perhaps example is if I take so I
would take P which is not safe a charge
that's that that's alright if I take P
which is equal easy for this one this
occasion so Zn is s 1 and plus s KN
justice so these guys of course this one
has an eigenvalue which is a which is a
eigenvalue
but if we look him at the limiting
distribution of look at the limiting
distribution of of the singular values
here mean we can't underst
singular values in the same way by
taking it to visit times its conjugate
the limiting distribution limiting in
this region has a spectrum which which
ends at
- root K minus one so as soon as as soon
as K is at least three this one should
be considered as an outlier so we have
we have an obvious we have an obvious
outlier so this one is obvious and so
the question becomes do we have none of
these outliers
and basically our theorem states that we
don't have just state
next time which I want to present to
verify the shorthand statement of the
serum is non obvious gravity as n goes
to infinity so maybe I should but in
something I think it's already possible
to make a rigorous treatment out of this
but but let me let me precise a little
bit though what we what we do is we take
M we take self-adjoint elements here oh
yeah and by the way so this is true here
I should measurement this is true for
any P which belongs to the matrices
and matrix valued coefficients in then
so what you do is to remove the obvious
parts we are going to to the youth to
view as I n not anymore
as acting on C to the N but on the
orthogonal of the pair of Albany's so
they are acting as endomorphisms of also
one of the devil hobo news
letitia's
you can think of it as an N by 1 times n
by 1 matrix so I will I I will call them
s tilde
I'm ok and then what I do is I
I call so PNA already defined it so we
define pitied on P to the N which is a
matrix in M n minus 1 of C which is all
things by replacing not anymore by si
but by STI I by s tilde by N and then
what we have is what we want namely that
we're in the mural
the probity
Oh yet the operator norm of P tilde n
figure so for any epsilon an operator
norm it's bigger than the operator num
of P plus
so here well that's an that's
well-defined what I mean here is what I
mean here is that I view my view as an
element's as an element of the bounded
operators of l2 if you prefer to it's a
slightly simpler to each be I had I had
this this priority major mu P which I
could which I could compute and this is
just the spectral the spectral radius of
the product
Lux
in support of you so that's that's the
statement
and lets me it seems to me that these
two statements I'm not technically
equivalent I mean I mean the first
baseman looks like as if you say that
Rondon dealers in graph this Ramon which
I'm with high probability the other one
is more like the see when I move that
the random didn't go that is has a this
two x squared minus one yes I agree with
your statement yeah I agree with there's
a very good very good question the
statement here just say something about
you know what happens on the on the
right basically and for example let's
assume which like I said is not
impossible is bigger than one that you
have a spectrum which is not connected
then then what I claim here is that even
in the middle even in the middle there
is no outliers so in the sense I'm
cleaning I'm claiming more here and
there it turns out that I have actually
a quantifier on the permanent this is
true for all perennials so then there
are some you know there's some tools you
can somehow you can fold your PO in the
middle like square it and then you know
well it turns out that these two
questions actually these two statements
are argument but it's not not completely
obvious but this happens to be the case
okay so well what I should perhaps do
now is the last 10 minutes right explain
a bit how well a little bit of them of
history and outline of the vein of the
proof so well first of all of course and
that was icing created to to your
question the particular case of ash
voice of I suppose of n plus Sen
this is undirected Schreyer graph or
something like this is of course of
particular interest because what what
this tells is that this is with high
priorities is close to total Ramanujan
so with high probability
this is close and there exists there is
proof of this result
I mean stick bought bought while
preferred of written manner about the
knife who under this so in the case we
can so this is just one particular
premium and we can you can view this as
a as a particular case of our theorem we
can also you know even though I'm not
going to comment too much on on this we
can also view our thermos as handling
much more gross than just this just of
graphs but so somehow this was Bowden
have point of view and my point of view
was slightly different probably Isaac
ultimate it was less interesting but but
somehow this problem was also quite
quite important in in in operator
algebra so in the penitentiary we are
interested in you know finite
dimensional approximation property of of
some fundamental G brother or sister
algebra so there are lots of them lots
of complicated objects and you would
like to know if if they can be
approximated by finite in some sense by
finite matrices also so perhaps you
heard of the
[ __ ] embedding program which is not
copyrighted related to this but which
which was somehow inspiration to to some
extent and so somehow the prime of
approximating what we call the free
group mister algebra freedom funnyman
algebra led to some previous results
results which were that well received
the same
[Music]
all truth holds true if one replaces
random permutations as i-n by random
hari tourism random mean tourism so this
becomes really actual random matrix
theory whatever group which has a unique
left and right invariant property which
are the hard measure and instead of
taking one dimension we drop the higher
the haar measure and then the results
the result holds true and that was
actually something which which had been
opened for quite a while in maybe for
for 10 or 15 years and at least in
operator algebras so there was a very
big first step which was which was
achieved by a hugger pinto beans on
ron's 1518 years ago while they proved
it for something short gue caution
Rotarians others and then together with
with cami mal we proved it for random
the uterus so in a sense our point of my
point of view at least was well you know
let's let's replace this probability
measure by another one and see what
happens was not a word that odd what was
at stake on them on the graph
theoretical point of view but it turns
out that the proof here is actually
easier than the proof there because this
is a continuous measure on the group and
we have lots of very powerful analytic
tools like we have some things like you
know shrink condition speak shrinking
Dyson equations and all this so lots of
things which which don't work if you
have a discrete measure so so any tools
which were available here we are not
available there and we needed some
oh it's even though it's at first sight
looked like a like direct extension lots
of new tools were needed and I will just
finish by by mentioning two two
ingredients of the proof so two
ingredients one which i think is a very
well-known bye-bye graph by people in
graph theory and one which is very well
known in operator algebra so we start
with the one in Inupiat algebra which is
which is a called the linearization
trick and the statement is as follows so
the way I could stay tuned here's the
tricky that it is enough the serum main
serum
is in M L of F K of degree 1 degree 1 in
the world
so namely something like this maybe I
could write like this a minus K tense g
minus k plus a 0 g 0 k tense gk where i
take the two congressional - k g- i SG i
inverse so if I can handle this
that's enough and this is quite
surprising at first sight this is quite
surprising because here we have a
statement about all polynomials so I
have a statement about degree 2 degree
whatever polymer and I'm I'm telling you
that it's enough just to look at
constant printers it's enough to look at
cotton polymers but of course there is a
price to pay for this it has to be true
for any matrix for any matrix confusion
I have a quantifier and for all and for
all
- Kay that's the linear is a trick and
once we have this we are in were already
in better shape
I'm already having descended anyway even
harder winter isn't used this trick so
somehow this trick had been known
forever in operator algebra it was
introduced by by by PCEHR for the study
of operator spaces and all this in the
70s also but it is I think huggable
internal person who realized that it can
really help to solve some some important
problems which are not only
interactivity to operator algebras and
then it it got really publicized quite a
lot in random matrix theory
so so that that's a that's that's the
first three and the second one is so
since we may not use analytic techniques
by analytic techniques basically I mean
this plus some complex analysis related
to still just transform and since we may
not do this because we don't have some
nice change of variable formulas and all
that we have to use moments techniques
and moment techniques don't work
directly this is handling this with
science or matrix value or this is just
too complicated but that's not a
surprise
I have on the stats that's know for
these random graphs similar problems
already occurred and and actually one
things which works is is to use some
some non backtracking some backtracking
operators so we have to do some non
backtracking operators so not about
writing a person again as far as I
understand were studied quite
systematically if you had one
coefficients all around here or at least
maybe complex you know I mean whatever
and scalar valued coefficients so what
we just saw to say had to do is is to is
to check which kind of non backtracking
theory we get if we replace scalar
coefficients by matrix valued
coefficients and it turns out that
actually extends Dragon Naturally and
then we are
everything boils down so to say to to
computing moments not of this but of a
non backtracking of of an operator of
valued non backtracking matrix which is
associated to this program which even
though to me looks more complicated
becomes becomes tractable in in terms of
of competitions
[Applause]
so doesn't allow to prove reproof
Friedman theorem and the easier way yeah
I mean so so shall Borden I've actually
have wrote wrote a paper where were he
here approves a Friedman theorem and
somehow I would say that that our that
his paper in a sense is a strict subset
of our papers or so it is really
techniques which he which is not
developing in his paper which we
extended to the illusion context
so this relationship between the non
backtracking and actual matrix is
something like the harvest yes there is
a quadratic relation between solar form
yeah yeah
so but the eigenvalues of the non
backtracking maker because it's not
normal or probably not nice right yeah
yes so right so so in the I was a little
bit quick when I when I did all this a
true daenerys new trick has has many
versions so there was a unitary version
it was a general version there is a
self-adjoint version so somehow the
separated version was was was quite
useful in in the beginning we are also
using the self as a fighting version so
you know we take we will ask this guy to
be the adjoint of this guy or something
like that but indeed the number tracking
matrix will not be M will not be a
normal and then we have actually to to
look at the spectral radius so you only
use the spectral radius
[Applause]
again a 415 for